أريد أن أتحدث إليكم عن المنصة
بالإضافة إلى منصة messenger rna التي
تعد
قطعة علمية ثورية ، لذلك
لم نستخدم هذه المنصة من قبل
لإنتاج اللقاحات وتوزيعها بهذه الطريقة
كما أعتقد في الماضي
أسبوعًا على وجه التحديد عندما وصلتنا الأخبار
حول
لقاح pfizer و biontex
هو الحاجة إلى التخزين البارد والظروف الباردة بشكل لا يصدق
والمضاعفات
التي تحدث في توزيع هذه
اللقاحات على نطاق أوسع ،
يمكنك فقط مقارنة متطلبات
لقاح Moderna وما
إذا كان هذا يجعل الأمر أسهل
التوزيع أكثر من بعض
المنافسين
أولاً ، دعني أقول أنه كما قلت في
المناسبات السابقة لقد كان من دواعي سروري
أن أتحدث معك جوليا
هو أننا ندعم كثيرًا
ونريد لقاحات متعددة
أن
يكونوا متاحين وسيكون لكل منهم
نقاط قوة وضعف نسبية
لذلك سأقول إنني
سأهنئ زملائنا في شركة Pfizer
على قيامهم بالفعل بجمع البيانات
بحاجة إلى دعم تقدمهم
لأننا نعتقد أنه من
وجهة نظر الإنتاج ، سيحتاج العالم إلى موردين متعددين
وبأكبر حجم أه متاح في
أسرع وقت ممكن
الآن لسؤالك المحدد حول
تكنولوجيا الحداثة ،
لقد أمضينا سنوات عديدة في الريادة في
مساحة messenger rna
وقد قمنا  كنا في هذا لمدة 10 سنوات
وفي السنوات القليلة الماضية
كنا نعمل بجد
للتوصل إلى تركيبات أكثر استقرارًا
للقاح تسمح لنا
بتجنب التجميد العميق ناقص 70 ناقص
درجة حيث كنا
قبل عدة سنوات
كما يسعدني أن أقول إن الابتكارات
التي قام بها علماؤنا
اللامعون في Moderna قد أوصلتنا إلى النقطة
التي
يمكننا من خلالها تخزين منتجنا في
درجة حرارة أقل من 20 درجة
وهي ظروف تبريد
متاحة على نطاق واسع
ولكن الأهم من ذلك اليوم  أعلنا
أنه بخلاف حقيقة أننا لسنا بحاجة
إلى ظروف التجميد العميق ،
يمكننا أيضًا التحقق من صحة الاحتفاظ
باللقاح
في ظروف التبريد التي تتراوح من
درجتين إلى ثماني درجات مئوية
لمدة تصل إلى 30 يومًا ، وهذا
تمكين ضخم أه لتتمكن من التوزيع
أه على نطاق أوسع بكثير
وبسهولة أكبر ، ونستمر في إجراء
تحسينات في هذا الصدد
علاوة على ذلك أظهرنا ذلك أيضًا
يمكنك الحصول عليه في درجة حرارة الغرفة
لمدة تصل إلى 12 ساعة بعد الخروج من
ظروف التخزين لذلك من نواح كثيرة
نعتقد أن هذا جزء مهم
من فائدة وسهولة
استخدام اللقاح والتي إذا كنا نتحدث
عن المئات
ملايين الجرعات سيصبح اعتبارًا مهمًا للغاية